I hate to break it to folks
but there's no magical Deus Ex marking a
device that is going to get you out of
this one
[Music]
so this is a indirect follow-up a bit to
the video that I made talking about the
planned reboot or remake or however you
want to consider re-adaptation of the
original Harry Potter books being done
as a TV series on HBO sorry just max now
that's God that's so dumb but there was
something that I didn't really touch on
but people brought up in the comments a
lot
and it is a thing for me every now and
then where something happens in the
comments so often that I hit a point of
okay I'm just going to do it rather than
reply to all these in text I'm just
going to do a video just gonna do a
video explaining the problem with this
thought process the thing I kept running
into were various permutations of
wouldn't it be great if JK Rowling would
sell the property and some people even
wording it like it was an inevitability
that Warner Brothers would purchase it
or should purchase it but like a general
desire from a certain stripe of fan I.E
people who recognize the damage that JK
Rowling is doing which I am not going to
be getting into in this video if you
don't agree with me on that I don't know
what to tell you I've done other videos
on it we're taking it as a given here
but people who recognize that but also
still hold on to a love of Harry Potter
which first of all it's a position I'm
very sympathetic to I was there for a
little while
it was I don't know about a month
between her original essay in 2020 and
when I took the Harry Potter stuff off
my shelf it was over a year two years
before I actually packed up the books
themselves uh and put them away I
haven't gotten rid of any of this stuff
because most of them were gifts so I
still have an attachment to them as
something given to me by someone who I
care about and cares about me even if I
don't want to look at them anymore so I
understand holding on to a love of these
things
I do get it and I understand how
just disagreeing with her not only just
disagreeing but recognizing the damage
she's doing but still feeling in love
with this puts you in a really awkward
position and in that position the desire
or the idea even
that she could somehow no longer be
directly attached to this property
that's very appealing
it's also not going to happen
like at all like ever like in our
lifetimes
now there is obviously always the tiny
possibility that I'm wrong on this but
I'm gonna be spending the next I don't
know how long giving you all the reasons
why I don't think I am so there's a
number of things that we need to
understand
first is a little bit about how uh
copyright and Licensing works
the intellectual property or IP that is
Harry Potter is owned by JK Rowling she
was the original creator of it she owns
the copyright to that IP Warner Brothers
licenses that IP for the purposes of
films video games and now moving forward
television now another thing that I'm
just going to touch on real briefly
there is also the park but it really
needs to be emphasized because a lot of
people didn't seem to get this either
Warner Brothers doesn't run the
attraction that Harry Potter is attached
to because that's in Universal Studios
which is owned by NBC Universal which is
a completely different company and they
also have a separate license agreement
now part of what they're licensing is
both the IP but also Warner Brothers
specific adaptation of it so Warner
Brothers probably does get a piece of
that but they don't run that and
um Universal would still in theory be
able to maintain that license through
their own agreements even if Warner
Brothers ever lets go over loses the
license to Harry Potter
um so another thing just to pick up on
that last video I did on this if Warner
Brothers ever lets go of the license
which my prediction was if they can't
get the full Seven Seasons out of this
re-adaptation then they will let it go
because this is the one thing that
should absolutely work and if it doesn't
they will make the decision to cut their
losses is my belief if they do they
don't use lose the rights to what
they've already made that's their
product they will retain the rights to
those movies those films and that game
which is published under Warner Brothers
the Hogwarts Legacy game they simply
will lose the license to be able to make
any more of that it'll probably also
lose merchandising rights and other
stuff but the actual things that they
made movies TV shows Etc they'll
continue to own that that's their thing
but they wouldn't be able to make any
more those rights would revert back to
JK Rowling so the idea of her no longer
holding
the rights
well let's first of all acknowledge the
fact that the degree to which she is
personally involved in anything
has nothing to do with the fact that she
gets a financial incentive for licensing
it out now this is relevant to Hogwarts
Legacy because one of the arguments that
people would sometimes try to make when
I would point out that buying that game
supports transphobia was that she wasn't
involved in the game and from any
creative perspective that's true if she
wasn't
but she still got the licensing fee and
probably residuals people would claim
she didn't get residuals and we don't
actually know because we don't see these
contracts but the thing is she's big
enough and has a large enough control
and it's a value enough property
whereas most IP holders of a book series
couldn't negotiate for residuals on a
per sale basis she could and I don't
doubt that she did I would be shocked if
she didn't if she didn't she needs to
fire her lawyer or her agent or whoever
it was who presented her with a contract
where that wasn't the case to be honest
but how much she is directly involved
with it doesn't impact
the fact that it still financially
benefits her
and so that brings us to the first
reason why she probably won't give it up
which is financial
she gets residuals on every book sale
every film uh copy you know ticket sold
she gets a piece of merchandise from
whether it be the parks or anything else
anything officially licensed like I said
she probably gets a piece of the video
game on a per sale basis
and
yeah that's a lot of money now you can
certainly make the argument she doesn't
need any more money when yeah that's
true but that doesn't mean that she
would just let that go
I think one of the comparisons that
folks like to make uh in regards to at
least thinking that she might pass off
the rights is George Lucas but I'll come
back to that because what happened with
George Lucas in Star Wars is a little
different let's cover some other bases
before we head down that rabbit hole so
the thing is that for her to no longer
have the underlying rights and again
we're not talking the licensing we're
talking the underlying IP rights she
would have to sell them or she would
have to pass away and we'd have to wait
90 years on top of that because public
domain generally it gets weird and wonky
in some instances but as a general rule
it's the life of the author Plus 90
years and when an author passes away
generally the IP writes if they have not
otherwise been sold which we'll come
back to they will revert to the children
or offspring of the original Ip holder
now generally with as much money as
would be involved in Harry Potter
there's probably a trust set up to
handle her eventual inevitable
passing away because we all do and that
will then manage it you you can find a
lot of things about
um how say the Tolkien estate uh either
was or wasn't pleased with various
adaptations of J.R.R tolkien's work
various Middle Earth uh related things
because that estate that trust continues
to manage those IP rights now that's the
first thing they do sort of go down the
line like any owned
asset would
that is assuming that she hasn't sold
the rights wholly which is something
that say George Lucas did with Star Wars
and George Lucas is an interesting one
to pull because on the one hand it's
he's one of the few instances of another
individual person who wholly owned the
entirety of the IP because generally
what you tend to get is you get you know
authors on on the intellectual property
rights to the thing that they wrote but
few things ever get as big as Harry
Potter or as Star Wars and generally
when you've got something that's
primarily a film franchise like Star
Wars the IP rights are actually held by
the studio
but those when he was directing them at
least were all actually
technically independent Productions
after that first one only the first one
was a studio film and the rest were
independent Productions and part of him
getting that first one made was he took
a lower fee but retained more of the
rights and that's how George Lucas
managed to keep in control of the thing
until he sold it so yes it is possible
for an IP holder to sell the
intellectual property the underlying
rights and to sell those to either
another person or far more likely and
entertainment conglomerate that will
then milk them for as long as they
possibly can
now
as I said while there are some reasons
to compare Georgia Lucas to JK Rowling I
also can't imagine her letting go of the
rights for the reason that he did
because first of all remember while he
sold Star Wars and well technically he
sold lucasfilm and the rise to Star Wars
and Indiana Jones and a bunch of other
stuff while those were sold for billions
of dollars he also donated pretty much
all that to charity he didn't want the
money but like it was how it was going
to be you know formalized and he tried
to do some good with it after the fact
but he definitely didn't need the money
and so he also clearly didn't need the
money for the residuals but the thing
was George Lucas seemed kind of done
with Star Wars it really did seem like
part of the reason for him to pass on
it's not that he didn't care about it at
all anymore but he didn't want to have
the obligation to keep managing it
because it was his if anything was going
to be done with it in the future he
would have to be involved in he just
seemed to want to do other stuff or at
the very least not be doing that all the
time
and JK Rowling
I know she's been writing other stuff
but she keeps coming back
to Harry Potter at the time the George
Lucas sold Star Wars he'd finished with
making any actual Star Wars stuff
himself over a decade ago Rowling's
still trying to get stuff done and made
we've got this re-adaptation which she
is directly involved in and even before
that we had the Fantastic Beast movies
which she was directly writing the
screenplays for so she doesn't seem to
be done
so there just doesn't seem to be a
reason I mean also keep in mind George
Lucas is a fair bit older than her so if
she's ever going to be like I'm done and
I'm tired if you're using George Lucas
as a comparison there's probably a
couple of decades worth before that is
even really viable but I said money
doesn't really make sense to me as an
incentive honestly for her to either
keep it or sell it
she doesn't need more money now which is
what you would get for selling it
whereas the residuals are a constant
thing and she doesn't really need the
long term Because unless she somehow
gets taken in and I don't know an nft
scam or something like she's never gonna
be hurting for money ever so money's not
really the issue here well it's not for
her anyway it might be for Warner
Brothers Discovery but again I will come
back to that
no I think the bigger issue here
is clout
her relevance in pop culture no matter
how much she tries to make her Thriller
series a thing and it's really not going
well you may have seen a headline a
couple of weeks back saying that the
prophets of her production company were
down like 70 some odd percent it's worth
noting that has nothing to do with Harry
Potter because her production company
manages her Thriller series and
adaptations of that and that's what is
down so like she keeps trying to make
that a thing it's not really working
so she's not gonna get a ton of cloud
off that but like when I say clout what
I mean by that why did why would she
want that what is she using that for
well to attack trans people is what
she's using it for but the thing is
that's what her platform is based off of
and she has made it
her full-time job practically at this
point to be on Twitter or to be in
interviews claiming to be attacked and
actively attacking trans people
particularly trans women and trans
rights again I'm not trying to go down
this Rabbit Hole again don't ask me to
cite two examples do your own looking
into stuff I've done videos other people
have done videos I'll put links in the
description okay if you want stuff to
look for there you go there's your
resources
go
but if we accept that which hopefully if
you're still watching you do if we
accept that that is what she's doing the
reason she has the platform she does the
reason she has listened to as much as
she is the reason that she keeps coming
up and she's trending like almost every
other freaking day on Twitter
is because she is also the IP holder of
Harry Potter now would she suddenly
become irrelevant if she was not the
current active owner no no she wouldn't
but the fact that she is the fact that
she isn't detached from Harry Potter
means that every time Harry Potter
Trends or every time there's an
announcement related to Harry Potter she
gets to ride that for attention for her
views and even if you think that her
views are a good thing even if you think
that I think you have to grant me she
absolutely rides any Harry Potter news
as a way and an opportunity and a time
to push her beliefs more it's part of
what keeps her trending because
while she will always be the Creator and
while nobody can ever take that away
from her and she'll always have some
Cloud for that
the specific conversation about whether
or not continuing to engage with Harry
Potter supports her and enables what
she's doing wouldn't be a conversation
anymore if she didn't still own the IP
and the fact that she does means that
every time Harry Potter is trending that
conversation Trends as well which means
she Trends as well which means people
have eyes on her which means she has a
bigger platform for what she's doing and
I think she puts a lot of value in that
platform
I think for her because she believes in
the righteousness of what she is doing
that she would view that as priceless
and if she was ever going to put a price
on that which I don't think she would
not at this point in time
if she was going to put a price on that
I don't think Warner Brothers could
afford it
which I think is the last thing
I don't think
that and Warner Brothers will be the
prime candidate theoretically somebody
else could buy it
um but given that say Disney which would
be one who could afford it is being more
at least publicly and superficially
supportive of trans people she might
fundamentally not be willing to sell to
them as a company and that's the other
thing you need to remember her retaining
the underlying intellectual property
means she has say and she actually has
control over the final product to at
least some degree because whether she
was going to be executive producing this
new show or not she still has a
surprising amount of direct power like
it was her dictation that for that film
series they not hire any Americans that
it was all actual Brits in that movie so
she has exerted her power before but if
she doesn't own the IP anymore
then she doesn't get to exert that power
they can do something else they could
make a trans-positive message in her
world I don't think she would open
herself up to that possibility but even
if she was willing to the price she
would put on it I don't think any
company especially Warner Brothers is in
a position to pay that now
again maybe some would maybe some
wouldn't again but I really don't think
she would ever sell it but let's just
stick with Warner Brothers because
they're the most relevant they're the
ones who've been handling handling it
for the longest and if she did ever feel
like she'd be willing to probably put a
price on it they're the ones who she'd
probably have the most Comfort would not
completely redirect or screw up or do
something she didn't want
Warner Brothers big thing right now has
been cost cutting yeah they're
announcing a lot of projects but largely
DC related largely stuff that they know
there's a built-in market for but
they're removing stuff off of HBO Max
they are cutting this canceling that not
releasing finished films all this in the
name of cost cutting and understand
they're not cutting that cost to
redirect funds they're cutting that cost
to cut costs
they are trying to clamp down on their
spending and they're trying to do it
hard and the idea of spending I can't
imagine she'd ask for less than George
Lucas got for Star Wars the idea of
spending four billion dollars on
attaining the IP and that's before you
even start production on any of it
that's just to own it that's four
billion dollars in the red in the whole
just for the purchase
I don't think they can afford it
now I especially don't think they can
afford it given what I said in the last
video about the state of the property
overall which is that
I don't think they have a ton of faith
in it right now I think part of the
reason they're doing the TV show is it's
the safest bet the spin-offs weren't
great I saw a ton of the comments people
were like why aren't we getting a
Marauder series well if Fantastic Beasts
had done better and was still continuing
maybe they would have done that but
they're going to the safest possible bet
or at least what appears on paper to be
the safest possible bet because I think
they're really uncertain about the
future of this property because if they
can't get this TV series to blow up and
stay blown up for the entire run of it
then they might not be able to get
enough to have it be worth even making
more product much less shelling out to
own the entire thing if you're going to
spend that much money you gotta know
you're gonna make it back
but I don't think they can afford it in
addition to that even if they could I
don't think at this point in time at
least that they have the degree of
confidence that would be required for
them to pull the trigger on a deal like
that
the thing is if she did sell we don't
really have a metric for what that looks
like in terms of the problematic Creator
no longer being involved in the product
but still being around
like the closest we've got is Minecraft
and its creator Notch who is I'm not
getting into all the stuff with him but
he's revealed himself uh over the last
few years to be
a very unpleasant person and Minecraft
continues to thrive the thing is
he'd sold Minecraft to Microsoft
before
most of the stuff that has tainted the
image of him in people's eyes happened
he sold his controlling stake in uh
moyang or Mojang or however it's
pronounced to Microsoft in 2014 and it
wasn't until 2016 when he started
posting stuff and making statements that
maybe will made people go
hang on a second so in a lot of ways
Microsoft lucked out because while it
may still have tainted the brand in the
eyes of some people because it
originated with a person they took
distaste with he wasn't involved anymore
by the time that happened
Rowling's been around now for going on
three years since it became undeniable
what her positions on trans people were
I know some people do still try and deny
it but you know there'll always be some
the thing is
it's not the same situation at all
people have already had to try and
reconcile their love of this with their
potential severe disagreement of her
and I think
the continuation of wanting to try and
reconcile that is part of what drives
the desire for the idea that she might
not control the property during our
lifetimes but again I don't think that's
going to happen
and I know it would be really nice
if more creators could be like say Neil
Gaiman and his work on the Sandman
Netflix series where Not only was he
open and willing to changes he
specifically was open to changes to
things that he felt either didn't age
well or he didn't get quite right in the
first place he's admitted to the flaws
in his own work something which rolling
is never done it's always a little bit
of a red flag for me just broadly
speaking if someone is defending to the
hilt creative decisions they made more
than a decade heck more than five years
ago but definitely more than a decade
ago
because like nobody's perfect
and
the way that early has responded to
credit you forget the train stuff for a
minute the way that she has responded to
criticisms of her work in regards to the
pictures of things like the house selves
and the goblins and anyone who could be
considered fat
you know those criticisms have always
been valid but she's never come around
on them she either ignores them or
defends her choices and her work
she's not going to prove herself to be
like Neil Gaiman and open to refitting
the work to be more appropriate
every indication is this series is just
going to be about putting even more of
the books than was in the movies and
that is potentially going to mean
carrying over a lot of problematic stuff
that got cut again a lot of the house
self content
I think in a lot of ways the movie's
lucked out because they could use the
excuse of cutting stuff for time whereas
the show won't have that excuse and it's
going to be up on screen
and it's going to get real uncomfortable
I think if this thing moves forward
actually has the potential to shine on
an even harsher Spotlight on some of the
flaws in the original work and again I
loved that book series I loved those
movies I loved that property but it was
always flawed in many ways so
why did I make this why did I feel the
need to list off all the reasons why
look she's not going to sell it folks
because I think some people
are clinging to Hope and again I I get
why
um
but I I worry that some folks have a
reluctance to move on
because they're hoping against hope that
somebody's going to swoop in and buy
this get it away from her have her not
be involved have her not get direct
residual checks anymore
something
it's not gonna happen
and I think you all need to realize that
because while I think some of you do and
some for some of you it was a wistful
thought there were other folks who
really seem to be putting a lot of
emotional investment in that idea
and I don't think that's a good thing
for you to do and look
if she ever
sells the rights I'll have a lot to talk
about
I will have a lot to discuss in parse
and think through
about how I feel about supporting that
property going forward if she is no
longer directly benefiting from it
I don't know what I'll think because as
I said it would lower her Cloud it would
definitely impact
um her wall in the long term though
she'll get a big payout initially but I
would no longer be able to make the
argument that supporting anything
official Harry Potter related directly
benefits her
just like she would no longer be able to
make the argument that any sale of Harry
Potter stuff is proof that people at the
very least tolerate her views if don't
agree with her
and if that's no longer the case
I may have to reassess and if that ever
happens
I'll be here to talk about whatever I
end up thinking
but the thing is
part of the reason I don't do a lot of
speculative stuff
is that I don't have a brain that lets
me go too far down a rabbit hole that I
think won't ever happen
it's why I'm I'm really bad at sort of
how would you rewrite this or what story
would you do for this property or where
do you think this will go like I don't
know I'll give you my thoughts when it
happens but I don't know
just because I can't Wrangle my brain to
sort out these big what-if scenarios
because part of me is going why are you
wasting your time and energy on this
it's never going to happen
and that's me
I know not everybody's like that and
that's why well part of why at least I
suspect some people still cling to that
hope
I've said before and I stand by
that you don't have to give up your love
of the property
you don't have to get rid of the Harry
Potter stuff you already had
what you can't do at least not while
claiming
to support and be an ally to trans
people is continue to buy new things in
this property under this IP
because it is directly going to somebody
who is using the clout the attention
and also the money to harm us
so
I know it's hard I know when something
you love is continuing to make more
it's hard to turn away from that even if
you've got the stuff you already loved
even if you've got the original books
got the original movies got merchandise
that you purchased before the end of
2020 even if you have all that you're
seeing more made and it's hard it is
hard to just walk away from that and go
but I love this stuff and maybe I love
the new stuff too and
that is a sacrifice I mean yeah first
world problems I get it it's not a
massive sacrifice but like it is
it does hurt
it hurts to not participate
with something that you have a pretty
good sense you'd enjoy
it's again
I don't think an end of the world style
issue but like it's not a painless thing
I do get it
but if that's the reason you're holding
on to this hope
I'm sorry but I I think you might need
to burst that bubble
I can't do it for you I've given you
some reasons to maybe consider doing it
but
that's something you got to do for
yourself
if you're ready
that's it
that's why I don't think she'll ever
give up the rights in her lifetime and
uh it's why I um
I thought I needed to talk about it
what are your thoughts on any of this
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it patreon pays the bills and
enables me to do this as my living so if
you want to support what I do and my
ability to talk to you about this kind
of stuff well any amount is of great
assistance there's Perks at every tier
you're gonna hear some names during the
credits for some folks who are really
helping me out but don't worry too much
about it
what I really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council and I am just
running the meetings and until next time
this Council
is adjourned
[Music]
my thanks to all my patrons but in
particular I want to thank Robin Moore
Zubin LED fulla Sarvis to rock the thing
that goes doing in the anime Ruth Oliver
B solitary pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters imudelki
Leo the Boyd Auntie Kate 808 Becky
Sparks for Nabi likes the poodle Robin
Powell Tracy scrabot angry Casper Tim
price Adam RDL Taylor goddess Elita
Elida not sure ah David Hall Shayla
Gourley Rosalind Bennett you want to
hear me mess up your name too it's in
the patreon perks
I gotta work on that
[Music]
foreign